all right welcome everybody John Perry
here I am with stephan hurtubise hello I
am very excited about today we're going
to talk about linguistics which is a
fairly new field in science it is an
actual science a lot of people think
language literature you know but
linguistics is a science it is the study
of this natural phenomena that we call
language and very fascinating a fairly
new field and we've got an expert here
to talk with us about it oh so yeah to
start off let's give people this Russian
sentence okay and and and let them think
about it for a bit yeah yeah okay so any
set up or just given the sentence and
let them mull over it yeah they just
give the sentence all right all right so
uh more people have been to Russia than
I have
does that sentence make sense more
people have been to Russia than I have I
think about what you think that means
maybe even write it in the comments what
you think that means because we're going
to talk about this later it's a really
interesting sentence and I guess also to
start off with real quick about three
shirts yeah yeah I'm sportin NASA
because as you know the insight probe
has successfully landed and I'm kind of
celebrating that today a little bit late
and you are wearing yeah this is
actually a linguistics t-shirt
associated with the YouTube channel that
I I write for called the Ling space
the Ling space yes yes we could always
talk about that a little bit more but
basically this is a Christmas t-shirt
it's a sort of syntactic representation
of the structure of the phrase Oh
Christmas tree from the song
Oh Christmas tree wrapped around an
actual Christmas tree I don't know how
much what I want to get into the details
but if anyone's interested it's
available at our store that's sweet
awesome oh I'll have to put up a link
for that Mary
towards also put up a link to your so
the yeah that YouTube channel so yeah
well let's dig into I guess the history
of this science that we call linguistics
sure yeah and and why is it a science
versus yeah we can get into that into it
for sure so yeah you know as you
mentioned John I mean it's it's in one
way it's a very young field
I mean modern linguistics you know
arguably dates back to the 1950s the
1960s you could sort of get away with
dialing it back to maybe the end of the
19th century beginning of the 20th
century depending on how you know how
far you want to go back in terms of
precursors to Noam Chomsky which is sort
of the father of modern linguistics but
maybe focusing on on Chomsky a bit since
he's been so influential in the field
you know he started this project of
approaching language from not only a
scientific perspective but more narrowly
a psychological perspective so you know
he's he played a big role in beginning
to view language not just as this kind
of I don't know object that floats out
there in the world but something that is
realized in people's brains something
that is a fundamentally human activity
and something that we can actually ask
questions about and get answers to as
long as we ask those questions in the
right way
and approach getting at those answers in
the right way in this case I mean
scientifically right so it language is a
natural phenomenon just like a storm
just like a mountain yeah and it can be
studied very analytically yeah
absolutely precisely yeah is something
that you had mentioned to me wouldn't we
we wouldn't had drinks the other night
to talk about this ahead of time the use
when you were studying linguistics you
studied French speakers right and it's
common for linguists to study a study
communication in a language that very
familiar with because it helps you step
away
from your own like we use language all
the time so it's hard to study it right
you're studying if you if you speak
English and you're studying an English
speaker it's hard to realize what's
actually happening there yeah so you
know for sure you can you can do Linc
good linguistic research on your own
mother tongue your native language it's
possible but yeah there is kind of this
interesting barrier I think people have
a hard time getting over the idea that
we really can study language
scientifically and and and we really can
get at these questions um I think people
kind of feel a little bit like oh well
because it's it's fundamentally human
it's so tied into who we are or we can
never really step back enough to really
get you know get a good grip on it but
yeah I mean a lot of the time linguists
will rely on the judgments and behavior
of speakers of a language other than
their own usually when they you do
enough research you become familiar with
the language anyway over time but you
still end up relying ultimately on the
speakers of the language that's of
interest to you
obviously with you know the tools you've
developed so that you know what kinds of
questions to ask and what sorts of what
sorts of data you want to elicit from a
speaker of that language yeah and and
certainly that helps with the process
yeah for sure of of just kind of
objectifying it and and you know putting
it under the metaphorical microscope
yeah
you know but one of the interesting
things that I I was thinking about just
thing about the study of language is it
it almost seems like all of us know how
language works because we use it every
day but we actually don't I mean we we
understand how language works almost as
much as we understand how we make a
heartbeat you know it's something that
really does have to be studied yeah
objectively yeah this is something else
that it can be tricky to get across you
know people have a very very strong
sense that they know how their language
works or that they know how language
works in
general a stronger sense I think then
people have with the heart or you know
some other internal organ or system I
think people don't confuse themselves
with a cardiologist just because they
have a heart yeah but oddly enough I
think people can get a little bit
confused and think of themself as a
linguist yeah even if they haven't
really spent any time the studying or
getting about language and that's fair I
mean you know language is central to
culture it's central to human
civilization as a whole I think arguably
it would exist without it it's
fundamental to accumulating and passing
down knowledge especially in the form of
writing so it's kind of hard to get over
in that sense right it's kind of hard to
see past it as like oh wait there's
there's this thing that I could now
focus on look at and ask questions about
yeah yeah it really a strange phenomena
and the the thumbnail of this video was
Coco the gorilla right who was very
famous for being able to speak sign
language yeah and I think I mean that's
a little bit of a it's a little bit
blown out of proportion the way that
people think that this gorilla can
actually speak
I guess Coco passed away recently yeah
yeah within the last few months I think
but I think that before we can really
even understand why what Coco was doing
isn't true language in the sense that
you and I are speaking language right
now I think before that it's probably
gonna be good to talk about what our
natural language is sure what a pidgin
is and what a Creole is because this is
this is a really interesting phenomena
the pidgin Creole phenomena right yeah
so I yeah it could be a good say yeah
yeah how would you describe a natural
language yeah so I mean in one sense
natural language is kind of just
synonymous with human language not not
human communication broadly because
they're all kinds of ways we communicate
with each other they're necessarily
linguistic in nature I'm even the
clothes were wearing right now as a kind
of signaling a kind of communication but
another way of thinking of natural
language is in opposition to artificial
or constructed
that's a broad term as well on
artificial language could be a computer
programming language it could be the
language of logic which is a system of
symbols and rules about how to put them
together
it could be any number of engineered
languages that have been designed with a
particular goal in mind
you know let's say to modify or fix
language in some way we have like
Esperanto is probably yeah yeah the most
famous construe yeah then you'll hang on
yeah well yeah those are two great
examples I mean in the case of Esperanto
you've got what you might call an
exhilarating Ament people's other
languages um and it had a particular
goal in mind right it has a particular
goal in mind i mean i i'm not an
Esperanto speaker so an Esperantist
might be better suited to sort of get
into these questions in depth but
basically the idea behind Esperanto was
to create a language in which everyone
could speak with one another and which
didn't privilege anyone else's previous
existing linguistic knowledge so
arguably today English is very much the
lingua franca of the world it's or
certainly it's up there in terms of the
language a lot of business is done in
and that's just because we won Wars and
a lot of Hollywood contingent on the
culture and history etc and Esperanto I
mean in part is it's kind of this
attempt to say well we don't want to
give an unfair advantage to people who
grew up speaking English in a situation
where English ends up being the language
of Commerce and so it was sort of built
from the ground up in a way from a
cobbled together from a lot of different
European languages it was yeah yeah yeah
exactly
Klingon not so much yeah but but that's
another example of a constructed
language with a particular goal in mind
although in this case an artistic goal
right so yeah I mean especially these
days you know Hollywood and and alike
they get so into constructing these
worlds of fantasy and science fiction
that they actually end up hiring
linguists like me to design languages
for their culture whether it's Dothraki
and
Game of Thrones David J Peterson
designed that one but based off of the
original work of george RR martin clay
on was in another example of course of
yeah a language which was designed by a
linguist with the purpose of again
sounding good on the screen i mean
sometimes the goal can be to mimic a
particular existing language that you
just like the sound of and you know want
to go in that direction or sometimes it
can be a you know i want to design a
writing system that looks really pretty
yeah we had a question it's really
relevant to this natural languages are
there certain sounds that are common
among the different languages yeah you
can talk about sounds being more or less
common for instance a language can have
more or less vowel sounds so I mean
English has probably somewhere between
ten and fifteen it's kind of tricky to
count it depends on what parameters you
want to use I know which accent you're
using - that - yeah which which which
dialect
other languages have as few as three but
as you move from the languages with more
vowels to the languages with fewer
vowels there there is it's not random so
there tends to be a sort of a core trio
of vowels I think it's something like e
and boo which are sort of maximally
distinct from each other and then as you
move from that trio of vowels to
languages which add more distinctions
you you usually don't take those away
you add to them um in the in sort of the
domain of consonants yeah you get sounds
that are especially common and then you
get sounds that are especially uncommon
like the intra dental fricative which is
putting your tongue between your teeth
and going or then we have it in english
but it's actually a relatively uncommon
sound amongst the world's languages and
tends to give people including quebec
french speakers a lot of trouble with it
yeah it ends up being usually turned
into either a D or a T sound as opposed
to this continuous flow of air through
the mouth yeah and and an American would
see that as a speech impediment
the
you know because a lot of Americans do
the TRD sound too sure yeah they
considered a speech impediment yeah but
in fact it's just there's something
about it that's especially challenging
and which and which that in turn makes
it kind of rare the so I've noticed I'm
in Montreal now and the language here is
French and I am having major
difficulties distinguishing vowels in
French because my ears are not tuned to
it right but you were telling me that as
babies the babble that babies do right
really incorporates pretty much every
weird sound that every language has in
it yeah yeah so I can talk a little bit
about language acquisition here you know
that there does tend to be this sort of
you know universal order in which
children acquire the sounds of their
language obviously the end states end up
being very different but the beginning
stages end up being remarkably similar
and as you mentioned the babbling sounds
of young infants tend to be very similar
to each other regardless of the
linguistic environment in which they're
being raised and they tend to be
somewhat representative of the world's
language as a whole as a whole but then
that sort of gets whittled down whittled
down not just in terms of the sounds
they produce but it from this in terms
of the sounds that they can actually
categorically perceive really it might
be interesting here just to mention that
in terms of the actual acoustic signal
between different vowel sounds are
different consonant sounds it really is
continuous so you know the difference
between e and o and uh it's not
physically categorical right you can go
from EU right um and like our layman is
variation in between what's interesting
about the way the human brain works with
respect to these sounds is that we we
cut them up so we don't you know if you
were to graph a person's perception you
don't get this line of like as you move
from one file to another it sounds more
like one and then more like the other
actually you get this really strong
contrast where the human perception
quickly flips from perceiving once one
sound to another and eventually we lose
a lot of these distinctions we just
can't really hear anymore the
difference between you know a and yeah
and these minor variations that maybe
aren't contrastive in your own language
right but but our very distinct in
another language so yeah yes yeah to
another person's ears of course they'll
be like of course there's a different
sounds yeah I mean it may be an example
of this would be you know so we have we
have a certain degree of variation in
English where stop consonants like P and
T and K when they're at the end of a
syllable they're basically just in their
standard form P or T or K but when
they're at the beginning of a syllable
they're kind of followed up with this
little puff of air and you can actually
put a look a little piece of paper in
front of your mouth actually if you
don't mind maybe I would yes sort of
demonstrate that here so you know if I
say something like stop you don't really
see the paper moving at all
but if I say pot you actually see a
little bit of a movement there now
that's not something we hear it's
something that happens in English but
it's not something that's contrast if it
doesn't actually whether a P is
aspirated or not doesn't make a
difference in the meaning of a word but
in other languages it does other
languages actually exploit this
distinction so that put me upon versus
pot I mean I can barely say it without
aspirating the piano sound just because
it's sort of a part of my the rules of
the phonology of my language
you know those would be two completely
different words to another speaker who
actually cuts up the way that consonant
sounds happen in their hand in a
different way from how an English
speaker does it okay so a person's
natural language right we start out as
babies doing all kinds of gibberish we
then learn how to how do we Whittle that
away yeah and we start associating words
with things yeah yeah and we develop a
natural language and so we speak this
natural language we develop it as a
child then there are pigeons mmm which
urn are not so much natural language but
a pigeon is when two people that have
speak different languages come together
and are forced to cooperate
yeah and they start to invent and make
sure the - yeah so maybe we can sort of
work our way up from
and what that is to what an actual full
natural languages yeah and then maybe
look at a specific example so yeah as
you mentioned they're sort of there have
been these historical contexts where
disparate linguistic communities have
been forced together for usually pretty
bad reasons like the slave trade yeah
but they end up being forced and sister
into circumstances they have to
communicate with each other somehow and
so usually you get this cobbled together
system of various aspects of each of
their languages pooled together and turn
into this relatively simple
communication mechanism I say relatively
simple because it will use again the the
sounds and languages that are more
common as opposed to the ones that are
more rare its sentence structure to the
extent that it has sentence structure is
much more simple you're probably not
going to find a lot of embedded clauses
you know sentences inside sentences
inside sentences which you can normally
do with language but which is certainly
a burden
cognitively so in a pidgin I might say
coffee me drink sure yeah
and you the two people or the two groups
would start developing a super-simple
kind of a caveman language yeah I mean
maybe does it to talk about some of the
things that would lack you know it would
lack things like tense it would lack
things like agreement so the interaction
that we find in languages we can affirm
and it's subject or a verb and it's an
object where they change their shape or
their pronunciation depending on what
role semantically they're playing in the
sentence they lack aspect so that's sort
of a way that we talk about the
relationship of events with one another
they lack you know articles they lack
case I mean there's all kinds of things
that you don't find in a pidgin that you
do tend to find in natural languages
maybe I could focus in on particular
example here that's actually a it's a
nice case of actually being able to
watch a language come into existence so
in the late 1970s in Nicaragua in
Nicaragua you didn't have much of a deaf
community you had deaf people living in
separate homes
not really interacting with each other
very much and so at most the level of
communication they had with their
families was something that you might
call home sign a variety of
communication which is sign language
like but which again doesn't really have
a lot of the features that a full
working sign language has again the
things we're talking about like tense
and agreement and in sign language is a
full natural language yeah I mean as an
aside it's maybe worth mentioning that
sign languages I think people get maybe
a little bit misled here think that
they're just sort of a coded versions of
existing languages but there was
otherwise basically the same so people
might think ASL American Sign Language
is just kind of American English but
with managed manual gestures instead of
you know vocalizations that's not really
the case I mean there are hundreds of
sign languages across the world and
they're largely independent if not
totally independent of spoken language
so what what is something interesting
happened in the late 70s which is a
school for the Deaf was established in
Nicaragua and the intended purpose of
the school was to teach them Spanish
through lip-reading
so it wasn't actually to teach them sort
of a full sign language em but it kind
of ended up happening anyway so
basically there wasn't a lot of success
in teaching them Spanish but what the
kids did is out in the playground or out
in the streets they developed this
communication system by pooling again
pooling together their resources from
their various home sign systems and
creating again something that was fairly
pidgin like it didn't necessarily have
the full gamut of linguistic properties
but interestingly enough when when this
was around long enough and the older
kids began to pass it on to the younger
kids I mean you could sort of think
about what was happening there as
passing or filtering an input through a
young mind that was still in the process
of acquiring a language and I use the
word acquire here very deliberately
because you know again there can be this
tendency to think that we teach each
other language the truth
linguistic systems when you start to
study them they're incredibly
complicated and there's there's no
sensible way in which we could think of
them as being actually consciously
passed on from one speaker to another
the truth is that they're acquired in
the sense that children are exposed to
particular language and then basically
derive from that input a replication of
what was in the mind of their of the
speaker that they learned it from or an
approximation of it right so in most
cases this means a children acquires a
language from their parents but in the
case of this Nicaraguan sign language
what was in a what ended up happening is
younger children were exposed to a
pidgin which is not quite a full
language but our propensity as human
beings especially when we're younger to
impose patterns and structure on the
world is so strong that the language
ends up getting regularized or the
technical term here is creolized it
becomes a creole language which is a
natural language is animal language so
for example i was mentioning the fact
that pigeons lack something like verbal
agreements so you don't have much of
this in english but just to give people
a sense of what that means i say he
sleeps right versus he sleep contrast
with you sleep versus you sleeps right
so you get you get a slight change on
the verb depending on the subject of the
sentence and and you biden's do not have
that pigeon gender and not to have this
but the kids actually started injecting
verbal agreement into the language so
the really young kids still a language
acquiring age they would see this pigeon
being spoken by older kids basically
yeah and they would invent deeper rules
yeah yeah to that system and this is
fascinating to linguists because it's an
opportunity for one to see language
creation in action but more than that
it's an opportunity to look at a new
language the birth of a new language and
trying and figure out what are the
essential properties of language what is
it that the kids are adding into the
system that's maybe not fully there in
the input but there
in there anyway and then if they have
their own kids then they pass it on and
their kids speak this creole language as
well and and that's a natural language I
mean you know the punchline here is that
you can think of a natural language as
linguistic input whether it's it's full
and rich or whether it's impoverished in
the form of a pigeon gets filtered
through the mind of a child who's in the
process of acquiring the language and in
turn becomes a natural language so even
with Esperanto which we mentioned was a
constructed language you know a certain
degree of thought was put into its
construction but it in effect became a
natural language because people did
raise their children speaking Esperanto
so the language gospel again it got
filtered through the minor children yeah
so I mean in fact it's become a natural
language this to me and most linguist is
evidence that there is something innate
about language because you give you give
kids a half half produced language and
they create a full language out of it
yeah with all the different rules and
stuff the been things like English and
French have yeah and these are these are
rules that you would think took multiple
generations to establish but kids are
doing it immediately yeah just by being
young yeah just by being young and it
doesn't necessarily require conscious
effort on their part it they're probably
you know I doubt if you had a
conversation with the speakers of the
younger speakers of nikkor up and sign
language that they would be able to tell
you about verbal agreement I mean again
that that's a level of awareness of your
own language that you usually only
acquire through formal instruction or
you know spending enough time at home
thinking about it by yourself to figure
it out but but when adults come together
they only create pigeons they don't
create full languages yeah yeah I mean I
you know you don't want to rule out the
the possibility I mean certainly people
when they're adults they can acquire a
second language right so you know we're
kind of getting into the domain of how
easy it is to create and/or learn a
language when you're older
is when you're younger and there's
definitely a difference there there's a
difference in terms of ease and speed I
don't know that there's necessarily a
super sharp cutoff point but there's
definitely a decline
you know linguists talk about a
sensitive period or an aura or a sort of
a critical period where if you're if
you're a child and you're not exposed to
language within that particular period
basically we're talking about before
puberty you're gonna have a much tougher
time acquiring your first language and
also you know the same goes with second
language acquisition even if you've
successfully acquired a first language
if you're if you're now past puberty it
can be a lot more difficult to acquire a
second language then let's say if you
were grew up multilingual yeah so I when
I was in college I met a girl from Cape
Verde and this was a set of islands has
a horrible history it was where the
slave trade it's ten islands off the
east coast of Africa and the Portuguese
who were running the slave trade there
they broke up each Island into multiple
camps and they would when there was a
war between groups in Africa they would
purchase the losing nations and then
they would take him to these islands and
they would separate anyone who spoke the
same language they'd separate them on
different islands this I'll this is her
telling me this I've never like really
dove into their history but sure and
then they break him into different camps
so that essentially nobody could speak
the same language as anyone else there
and then they would break them and
prepare these you know normal proud
humans to be [ __ ] slaves in an absolutely
horrible process but she is a descendant
of that yeah so obviously there's a lot
of people that were kept there on these
islands and they ended up revolting
eventually I think it was really
recently that they'd gained independence
from the Portuguese I think it was like
a 70s oh wow very recent but they she
spoke Portuguese Creole and I I speak
Portuguese I lived in for several years
and so her and I became really good
friends but it was really interesting
habit because she learned proper
Portuguese at school but she spoke this
Creole yeah which was a mix of a bunch
of different African languages and
Portuguese and and yeah it was
completely naturalized language
everybody on the island speaks the same
Creole and it's a full-on legitimate
language mm-hmm but it started out as a
pidgin this transition from you know
pidgin to a natural language natural
Creoles was really fascinating to me and
it was it was so cool to listen to her
speak Portuguese and then speak her
native tongue yeah it's fascinating to
to linguists to it offers a very unique
peak that we otherwise don't get into
the the language acquisition and
language generation process yeah it was
also striking listening to her stories
as to how important language is I mean
that that was a key the Portuguese felt
that was key and breaking a human soul
is to make it so they can see it's such
a fundamental part of our identity
all right that's another sort of barrier
to studying a language is recognizing
how close you are to it and trying to
distance yourself from it to approach it
from a scientific perspective I'm right
to be tough yeah so let's talk about
Coco so all right people want to say
that Coco is speaking American sign
language sure yeah how is that true how
is that not true but what is the
difference yeah yeah so basically it's
highly controversial the idea that coke
of the gorillas actually spoke or let's
say used sign language American Sign
Language and I think I think part of the
confusion over this comes from again not
realizing that language isn't just a bag
of words right it's it's actually a full
system of rules that govern how those
words are combined and how they're put
together and what sorts of elements are
added to them so when you actually look
at the kinds of utterances or the kinds
of productions let's say is a better way
of putting it that Coco was producing I
mean for sure
Coco learned maybe it was in the hunt
maybe even the thousands of signs
individual signs you know so there we're
talking about an association between you
know let's say real world objects or
relationships and and then manual
dexterity so particular movements being
done in the hands that in and of itself
is is not really a language right I mean
language is so much more than that it
languages about the order that the words
come in and the kinds of grammatical
extra bits that are sprinkled into it
and on top of it and and the ability to
construct novel sentences right well
yeah so it you know you can talk about
this also in terms of how how languages
is used so I think maybe we could look
at it from the perspective of how easy
it is for a child to acquire language
which is to say we don't have to do
anything to make it happen it just
happens
versus a lot of these instances of
trying to teach non-human primates
languages are involving teams of
scientists desperately trying to get
this animal to in some way achieve a
human level of linguistic communication
it's incredibly difficult it never seems
to achieve quite the level of linguistic
communication that you and I have and
the end State yeah the end State never
seems to be quite there again I mean for
sure you found Coco as well as you know
chimpanzees that had been taught various
versions or various degrees of sign
language you found these sort of they
would just oppose signs they would
combine them whether that was truly
linguistic or whether it was something
more sort of behaviorist Accor
conditional in nature that's tough to
tease out right it's tough to know that
well maybe all that's really happening
here is they know that they know that if
they put this sign together with this
sign they'll get food or that water but
but she was able to say I want yes and
then you taught her one phrase
want food I wanna I want whatever yeah
but then she was able to understand oh I
want Kitty mm-hmm and so she could say I
want kitty even though she was never
taught I want kitty as a phrase right
yeah I think so another reason why it's
it's controversial to make that
particularly is I don't know if you have
ever heard or if your audience is heard
of the case of clever Hans which was
this horse that was supposed to be able
to do three-dimensional arithmetic and
so the the basic story was that this guy
was supposedly he supposedly had a horse
that you could throw the horse a couple
of numbers like two and three and then
it would use a tough to kind of tap out
the answer turned out that when you
actually examined the case closely
the horse was using Hughes from the guy
in other words the guy was doing the
arithmetic the horse was just kind of
following along with what the guy wanted
the horse to do and it made it look that
the horse was doing math with respect to
these novel combinations of of sines
like I want Kitty I don't think it's
entirely clear that that's not what was
going on then there wasn't this
incredible incredibly strong link
between the researcher and the gorilla
to elicit a particular response and I
mean it is another thing that's
important to point out here is that
language is I want one of this
characteristic features of languages is
that it's very much stimulus independent
so we produce all kinds of utterances
and ask questions without necessarily
there being some obvious stimulus out
there in the world other than our own
mind leading us to that statement or
that reg n and you don't really see that
in these cases of non-human primate
signing where there were these
spontaneous questions or these
spontaneous utterances that didn't
really clearly involve or in some way
involved the the research or maybe
eliciting this response so so you know
it if I look at a chimpanzee trying to
get food for example they're gonna go
through a whole set of things like you
know they can invent this they can have
a stick and put it in
get termites and all that so there
they're constructing a whole series of
behavior yeah right to get an end result
yeah you can even get pretty complex and
it would seem like Coco's doing the same
thing with words maybe yeah but if I'm
understanding correctly there's a big
difference between that and what we're
doing because we're kind of using
language to help us organize our own
thoughts it's part of it yeah for help
to help navigate ideas it's also
fundamentally a very social activity and
you know most of when you actually
measure what it is people talk about
like two thirds of it is other people
right it's basically gossip I mean it
we've sort of co-opted it to be used as
a system of complex propositional
knowledge communication like again build
rocket ships and go to Mars using
language but it's maybe not clear that
that's what it's usually used for or
even what it was originally used for
it's possible that just that just ended
up being a really handy sort of side
effectiveness yeah yeah it really is
interesting to try and tease out these
differences and I know that the research
is as you mentioned that this field is
young yeah
there is some research going on in the
United States with bonobos right now or
they're using symbols on I think it's
not like an iPad or something oh really
okay I don't know ends and these chimp I
think it's been all those they're
they're seeing how much construction
they can actually do with these symbols
yeah and it is seeming like they're able
to figure it out better than we thought
just with them mm-hmm just with the
experiments with Koko because yeah the
the experience with the experiments with
Koko weren't very well controlled she
only had one it's best that way it has
one data point is not a great way to do
science yeah yeah and you had you really
only had and the start I'm forgetting
the scientist name I apologize but she
was you know she was like the only one
doing this yeah and now we met this
laboratory that's that's investigating
is more with with multiple researchers
studying these this group of bonobos
right so I think we're gonna get some
more information about this to really be
able to tease out the differences yeah
yeah I certainly wouldn't want to
underestimate the intelligence of
non-human animal
my point would be to not underestimate
the complexity of language I think right
I think unless people have spent at
least a little bit of time studying it
you know whether it's reading a book or
taking an introductory course or what
have you
or watching our YouTube channel the Ling
space Ling space is it can be hard to
actually even imagine how how
complicated it really gets and you know
we can we can certainly get into that
but maybe a nice way to cap off this
part of the conversation would just be
to mention that if you actually just
turned to a human speaker or a human
user of ASL and you ask them you know
sign language yeah yeah what was what
Coco the gorilla was doing was that
anything like what you do and the answer
is an unequivocal no but there's nothing
like sign language so you know I mean I
would default to their judgement on that
one but it would be similar to a pidgin
right I mean she's chilly she's
basically just like in a pidgin I might
say money quantity food like if I'm at a
restaurant maybe um there may there may
be subtle ways in which it's not though
so I think it's not even entirely clear
how discreet the signs of Coco word by
discreet here I mean that you can
clearly differentiate one sign from
another or or from what other kinds of
manual movements were occurring before
and after whereas again another one of
these distinguishing features of
language is that it's fundamentally
discrete you know we have sounds that
are categorized by our minds even if the
the variable in the acoustic signal is
continuous we we break sentences up into
words we parse a sentence and we sort of
figure out on the fly what its structure
is and and again this is not something
you see in the signal when you actually
look at a recording of speech and a
visual representation of speech it's not
like you see the words and yet our minds
are immediately imposing this this
structure onto our utterances and I
don't think it's entirely clear that
what's what's going on in in in signed
languages as used by as
non-human primates is really discrete in
the way that that language is it made
them work continuous yeah we got a
couple of questions you're interesting
here am actually my brother asks does
learning two languages as a child make
it hard to be completely fluent in
either of them or can a child learn two
languages as fluently as just one
language
if taught them from birth hmm yeah so
it's not really my wheelhouse to be
honest with you but my basic
understanding with respect to raising
children bilingually or all multilingual
is that I think fears of of not fully
acquiring one or the other language are
overblown yeah and in fact I think it
goes in the opposite direction I think
it's it's demonstrably true that
children that have been raised by
lingually or trilingual et cetera
actually have an advantage in terms of
having that much more metalinguistic
awareness so awareness of a language as
an object of study you know you because
you have the opportunity to compare two
or more languages and actually think
about what the differences are what
their similarities are and that can only
be a good thing right all right right
all right well one of the things in his
question he talks about being taught
different languages from birth but what
you're saying is that language is not
taught it's acquired yeah I mean
obviously we don't I mean so it's maybe
this could transition into what happens
when we aren't exposed to linguistic
input but in most normal cases human
beings are exposed to a certain degree
of input which they then turn into a
fully functioning language I mean
languages in his essence reinvented it
with every new generation although often
the the replication is so close that we
don't notice changes except over long
distances of time so from you know a
parents to their to their children the
differences aren't enormous you can pick
up on them but the two languages are
still mutually intelligible yeah but
when you separate people over let's say
a thousand years you lose that
intelligibility so you know I it's it's
kind of neat just to I would encourage
people like maybe not right now but once
the video is over go over to YouTube and
check out someone reading the first few
lines of Beowulf in the original English
it's completely different from the way
English is today and it gives you a you
know he gets the imagination going about
what's what's English going to be like
in another thousand years now things are
different because we have we have
recordings of English now yeah it may
end up maintaining the language to a
degree that it wasn't maintained purely
through writing so maybe it won't change
as much maybe we'll be supplanted by
another lingua franca well okay so I I
want to talk about accents real quick
here okay because people a lot of times
I you know I'm from Oregon and I kind of
speak like someone from California and
people will say that I don't have an
accent and that someone from Tennessee
does have accent everyone it expands and
the neutral version of the language I
think that's really funny bits but but
first I got a really interesting
question do the vocal chords work more
constrained as we get older so you know
we're whittling down the the the things
that we're capable of understanding you
know right as we as we learn language we
go from total gibberish to just you know
what our language speaks in does that
affect our vocal chords that's an
interesting question I don't know if
that's been studied I mean certainly
people's voices change over the course
of their life over their lifetime right
a children's or a child's speech is much
more high-pitched than an adults in part
because their vocal cords are smaller
and they have the smaller lung capacity
as you grow older your lung capacity
grows your vocal chords get bigger and
thicker and your your vocal range tends
to lower your overall pitch tends to go
down I would if I had to guess I would
probably say that as you as you age your
vocal cords age along with you which is
to say they they probably lose things
like elasticity and that I mean
certainly if you listen to older people
speak versus younger people just in
terms of the pitch of the voice the
quality of it I mean even if you can't
see their face you can usually
distinguish an older voice from a
younger voice yeah so I would I would
imagine it probably associates with a
change in the physiology or ideology but
well I would say so I mean this question
is this the language that you speak
change how your vocal cords can work and
I would say absolutely yes it's just
like exercise anything that you
you know the muscles that you use
determine how your body is built you
know as you get older I was talking to a
doctor once who was complaining about
these have you seen these barefoot shoes
where all your toes are usually he was
saying that he got a lot of people in
with foot problems after using those and
the the marketing ploys that you know we
evolved to run barefoot so you should
you should be running barefoot and the
doctor is telling me your feet
actually transform to wear shoes if
you've been wearing shoes for a load I
had yeah our bodies are very plastic we
so I I think it's Angele you true the
muscles the specific muscles you use in
your vocal cords and in your tongue for
the language that you have been taught
or that you've acquired yeah that's
going to determine the strength of those
movements of your tongue yeah and your
vocal oh yeah I think I would just
qualify that that it probably has a lot
so you know when you actually look at
how language is mechanically produced
what tends to make one language
different from another or one system of
sounds different from another isn't
really tied too much to the vocal cords
so although all the vocal cords really
do is you force air through them while
keeping them taut so that they they
vibrate and it's really what we do with
that vibration that differentiates one
language from another so the position of
the teeth the tongue the lips the the
velum which is the soft palate which
either allows or blocks air going
through the nose these are all the ways
in which we can articulate different
sounds obviously we do play with the the
vocal chords a little we can make
certain kinds of distinctions using them
but they're pretty specific in terms of
what they do from one language to the
next which is basically they vibrate and
then we do something with that and to
make one vowel sound different from
another one consonant sound different
from another
so I mean phone additions or acoustic
phonons have this sort of source filter
theory of how voice how the voice is
produced where the source is really the
lungs in the vocal cords and then the
filter is the rest of our sort of
peripheral speech system but
that isn't her when I was in Brazil I
really think that everyone should learn
a second language and should travel to a
foreign country or just go hang out with
foreigners in your own country because
you you notice so many weird things and
I don't even know what I'm about to say
is true about English or not but I
noticed that in Brazil people would
speak high-pitched and it was almost
kind of a status for for males you would
speak higher-pitched if you were kind of
lower status and you would speak lower
pitched if you were higher status nice
interests and I would see this
especially with politicians who they be
purposely speaking low to make
themselves sound bigger yeah oh yeah and
but but I know it's the opposite like
men who who were very timid would speak
at an artificially high pitched tone and
I wonder if we do that in English this
is something that I would you know like
do we do that - yeah I mean that's sort
of an interesting sociolinguistic
question it's always good to ask what
are we still signalling with the
language rose and and what what is our
position in society with respect to how
we're using our language I don't know
too much about that
and yeah I mean I would say one thing
one thing that that what everything you
said maybe think of was just that
linguists do tend to think of the
lowering of the larynx which is the
voice box box which is the massive
cartilage that contains the vocal cords
right they think of that lower lowering
it that it is in an evolutionary sense
so versus our our ancestors as being a
precursor to language basically the
lower the larynx gets the more space we
have to play around with and filter and
so the more different sounds we can
produce with a language but it's not
necessarily clear that the lowering of
the larynx evolved for language because
it's it also serves the purpose of
actually making us seem bigger so
basically the lower the larynx the lower
the pitch and now you kind of get this
sense of larger size that's interesting
all right so before
forget I'm getting a lot of I'm getting
too many interesting questions this is
really good at a lot of times when I do
these videos I don't get enough
questions okay so this is this means
people are interested this is cool but I
want to talk about this accents thing
and this the evolution of accents and
the the evolution of the meaning of word
you talked about Beowulf if you were to
hear BAE Wolf being read in its original
English you wouldn't even be able to
understand it you might be able to read
it now I understand it but this this
this issue of the southern accent a lot
of a lot of times in America people
associated a southern accent with people
that are uneducated and tell us why
that's wrong oh well I mean what can I
say about that maybe here what I'll say
is that if you're right people do have
this subjective sense that certain
accents are associated with certain
classes you know whether it's
socio-economic or or or what have you
and I mean unsurprisingly people then
hear that dialect of English or that
particular language that's associated
with that lower social class as being
either a substandard version of their
language or their dialect or somehow
wrong or worse or broken or what have
you I mean there's there's this has no
objective reality in linguistics so you
know as far as linguists are concerned
there's no obvious way in which
different dialects or different
languages are really better or worse
than each other you can talk about the
differences but often it's more just a
matter of a kind of trade-off so um some
languages may be lets say simpler in one
sense and more complex in another so you
know you can count how many vowel sounds
a language or a dialect has and if a
language has fewer vowel sounds doesn't
necessarily follow that it's simpler
than another language that is more vowel
sounds they may be introducing
complexity in some other way oh maybe
they have a more sophisticated case
system a more sophisticated morphology
they have more tenses than than we do in
English let's say
well okay so people that speak my
dialect of English we when we hear
someone say I don't got no whatever
uh-huh we hear this double negative oh
and we think that's an indication that
you're not very smart or are you using
an inferior form of the language yeah
and the really interesting about French
is that double negatives are the formal
way to speak so you're supposed to use
double negatives yeah you know papi
buffle so everybody
I haven't even translate that directly
into English well usually the way it
sits it's translated by a linguist
sojanet Papa say I speak not French I
mean the nose is not really even
translated yeah because we don't really
have an analogue in English the
secondary negative particle particle
here is just a word for I don't know
what it is I'm going to call it apart
now maybe yeah yeah we do well I got no
it so maybe it's worth getting a little
bit into this because it so there's this
sense that let's say something like
double negation is illogical right that
it doesn't make sense to use two
negative words in a sentence because
they cancel each other and becomes
positive again I would point out the
fact that you know speakers of dialects
of English that don't obviously have a
double negative actually have an
analogous phenomenon that they're just
not aware of so there are there are
these words called negative polarity
items which sounds really fancy NPI for
short and they're words like ever and
any and certain idioms like give a damn
so I might say I don't give a damn but
it sounds a little bit weird to say I do
give a damn except in a particular
context or you can say I didn't ever do
that but it sounds a little bit weird to
say I did ever do that yeah so you get
these words that pattern with negation
or you know I didn't see anything versus
I did see anything you might say I did
see something that's sort of the more
natural way to put it so you get this
switch from some to any when you put
negation into the sentence and
that's essentially what's happening with
double negation and other dialects of
English it's just that instead of any
let's say you get something you get
something like no so I didn't see
nothing right versus I didn't see
anything
it's the same phenomenon or it's very
very similar it's just that in English
it's not obvious that it's a case of
double negation because any doesn't
really sound anything like no or not
there is and I didn't see nothing it's
more obvious that the no and nothing is
related to the not in didn't um so you
you get these patterns which again
people don't even realize exist and and
can't even really it's actually kind of
challenging to describe the pattern it's
tricky to explain you know why is it
that we could say something like
everyone let me see if I can construct
this in so everyone who's ever thought
about this as read a book about it
that's that sounds okay but it sounds
weird to say everyone who thought about
this has read any book about it like
suddenly when you move the negative
polarity item or in this case I switched
the negative polarity from ever to any
and put at the end of the sense instead
at the beginning you go from a good
sound ru you go from a good sound of
sense to a bad sound a sentence why well
we do have an explanation for that but
it well requires you know several
minutes and a wipe
yeah but you can certainly go to our
Channel and have a look at Eric yeah
sort of negative flirty items and that
might interest you as well yeah so the
essentially kind what I want to drive
home here is that the accent that you
use all languages evolve they emerge
within a culture and they they evolve
emerge from this there's this biological
aspect that all of us are kind of set up
to be able to create languages and so
the different dialect that you happen to
speak really has nothing to do with how
intelligent you are
it's just cultural associations so we
might we might notice that people that
don't learn never learn how to read
often talk this way because
weren't reading you know formal English
like like we were and so you'll
associate that with someone who's
illiterate yeah if it had been the other
way around
it would have been the other way around
so if if quote-unquote formal English
said things like I didn't see nothing
and it was the lower status version of
language that said I didn't see anything
then we would we would think of I didn't
see anything as being of low prestige or
low quality or a worse kind of English
to cry how illogical it is right why
would you say any when you could just
say no it's a this is really just normal
human prejudices being yeah about no
language the justifications that tend to
be put forward for why one version of a
language is better or worse than another
often fall apart under scrutiny
maybe always fall apart under scrutiny
and as a surprise surprise
usually just follow along cultural and
political lines yeah predictably yeah
let's see I've got a question about is
there a specific region of the brain
responsible for for language I'm not
sure if that's something you would know
about but I could just briefly address
it and say that yeah there are a couple
of regions of the brain so for one
language is highly lateralized in most
people it's realized in the left
hemisphere as opposed to the right and
it's also highly localized in a couple
of areas what's known as Broca's area
after the researcher I forget his first
name in Broca
as well as Verna Q's area again at named
after a researcher Broca's area seems to
be highly correlated with certain kinds
of grammatical aspects of speech
especially people with damage to Broca's
area have a lot of have a hard time
understanding passive sentences yeah
damage to Verna Keyes area seems to
relate more to meaning as opposed to
grammar or structure so yeah you do find
these pretty tight correlations between
certain brain areas and certain aspects
of language yeah I got another question
well we want to be able to fully
understand animal language and
communicate with them and I hope so yeah
I mean it seems like it should be doable
but there's some really interesting
things about this
I was I was reading it was like a
popular article it wasn't a scientific
research article but so I don't even
know how to accurate this is but there
was some sort of experiment with
dolphins hmm that seemed to suggest that
they can actually communicate
three-dimensional objects with each
other oh did you hear about this yeah
right right I did hear about this yeah
because they see with sound the United
so NAR right and so if depending on how
good they are imitating sounds they
could also chirp that image to each
other yeah in an instant which is really
coolest and file transfer yet and for us
to be able to learn how to do that would
be that would be complicated
but I suppose we've already got sonar
systems so you could we could probably
get a sonar system to talk to another
sonar system that's what we do with
technology we supplement our bodies with
what the things they can go through
through our own invention yeah but so
much of animal communication is with
gestures and you know like a dog barks
and the bark sounds pretty much the same
all the time you've got different
squeaks and other things like this and
obviously there's information in that
and the dogs are understanding each
other at some level to a degree
according to these sounds but for the
most part with dogs it smells and its
posture and it's I mean not those not
that those things are unimportant in
humans but again a you know a bark is
very different from a language with a
million word vocabulary and a
sophisticated system of grammar that can
in principle generate an infinite number
of sevens answer which communicates a
completely different idea all right
right and the fact that we're so good at
communicating through writing or through
telephone that kind of suggests how
dependent we've become on language as
opposed to body gestures absolutely yeah
that's a good point yeah because we
really can understand someone's mind by
reading what they wrote yeah yeah I mean
just look look around you all the
technology around you the building's the
the civilization that you live in as a
whole really wouldn't be able to have
gotten there gotten off the ground
without being able to transmit complex
information and accumulate knowledge
through history yeah I got a question
what are Stefan's thoughts on the
sapir-whorf hypothesis your native
native language altering your thinking
patterns yeah right so I guess briefly
like the case with Coco the gorilla or
other instances of non-human animals
communicating in apparently linguistic
ways linguists are pretty skeptical
skeptical of stronger forms of the
sapir-whorf hypothesis so in this case
the stronger form of the sapir-whorf
hypothesis named after Benjamin Lee
Whorf and Edward Sapir two researchers
at the beginning of the 20th century
looking at language the basic idea is
that in the strong form the hypothesis
says that are experienced in our
perception of the world is fundamentally
constrained by the language we speak a
weaker form might just say that it's
influenced by the language that we speak
and I think without a doubt there's a
lot of experimental data that shows that
yes languages do the language you speak
the vocabulary that you have it does at
least nudge your perception in one
direction or another you can sort of
measure this in experiments those are
not just tend to be really really small
so you know we're you know in terms of
let's say color perception where a
language like Russian makes a different
lexical distinctions between different
shades of blue versus English which
doesn't so maybe maybe the equivalent
would be the fact that we have were we
have a word for red and a word for pink
but we don't really have words for
different shades of blue we just have to
say things like light blue and dark blue
right or whereas Russian actually does
make this distinction more pronounced
and you can actually measure the speed
with which a Russian speaker can
distinguish between different colors but
the measurement is usually on the order
of milliseconds right so the idea that
it's fundamentally changing the way they
see the world that seems to be a bit of
a leap and again you know it might also
be just worth with mentioning again at
languages more than just a bag of words
right I mean languages primarily this
big giant complex grammatical system and
I mean there have been attempts to try
and show that that influences thought in
a fundamental way there was an economist
a few years back by the name of Keith
Chen who whose research basically
claimed that the way the different
languages mark tense that is future
versus past versus present actually
influenced saving behavior when and like
like Monday right and he did a pretty
good job of controlling for all the
variables you'd want to control for
right you want to filter out culture in
this context which is hard to do because
language also is very tied to a
particular culture but he did a pretty
good job to his credit um it still
wasn't convincing not to me and not to a
lot of linguists that this that that I
think its idea was basically that
languages which didn't mark the future
tense actually had speakers that were
better able to save because they didn't
draw this distinction between the here
and now and the later
whereas speakers who did make a
distinction between the future and the
present
somehow they know cleaving time in this
way meant that they the future was
conceptually more distant and no they
wouldn't say for it I I don't it's hard
to buy because for one the way that the
end of categorizing languages in terms
of which ones have a future tense and
which one didn't really line up with the
way that linguists the way categorized
in the way that languages do or do not
mark the future for one thing it's worth
saying that and any language can talk
about the future and they do it in
different ways but it's not as though
they're languages where people have no
idea what's going on and the future just
doesn't exist and and moreover you know
in English for instance doesn't actually
have a future tense proper it uses a
modal verb like will or would to talk
about the future this is versus the past
tense which is a suffix that you add
right kick versus kicked the IDI
sentence at the end it turns turns a
verb into the past tense so we do future
a little bit different in English we
don't really have future tense per se
but in in Keith Chen's research he
categorized English as being
future that is having future tense and
Minoso these categorizations were odd
you always want to be wary of research
in a field that's done by someone who's
not in that field
yeah each end with an economist not a
linguist I don't want to you know sort
of crap on his research too much but and
there have been subsequent studies that
have tried to control for yet more
variable but you want to be skeptical
about that sort of thing and I think I
think at the end of the day my take-home
message would be you really want to
start you want to start from the data
and and see what that tells you you
don't want to start from a conclusion
yeah and work backwards from that you
know you don't want to start with well I
I think you know language probably
influences thought let's let's look for
what confirms that I bought this is I
ignore anything that doesn't exactly
don't want to do that exactly and that
is kind of one of the problems with the
cocoa experiments is that and that's one
of the criticisms yes that she was
really wanting to communicate yeah there
was a strongest desire to have a
particularly so so now we're trying to
figure this out with with more controls
which is really interesting well just
for time I want to I want to end here
but then if you're willing to do a
couple more questions absolutely um just
in ending I want to let you know that
his YouTube channel which he writes for
is the Ling space
so the Ling space so Li ng and yeah it's
wonderful he's got you got interviews
with different linguists you've got
oh yeah just lessons on language yeah
yeah we've got some more you know
introductory stuff that I think anyone
could get something out of we have some
more advanced stuff that you tend to
only it's sort of it get exposed to at
the graduate level and then we have more
general interest videos and I think lots
of interviews which people would find
interesting as well you've had Steven
Pinker on if you had well we've had Dan
Dennett on it we've had the evolutionary
biologist it comes to fetch talk about
the evolution of language we've had Lisa
pearl talk about various specific
problems with how how we let's say
associate the position of a word in to
in a sentence to a particular meaning
for that word it's called the linking
problem she talks a little bit
that I know even with people talking
about sociolinguistics as well I mean we
tend to use our interviews to really
supplement our own maybe a lack of
knowledge in a particular field and get
them to help us out a little bit yeah
cool
all right now now let's let's kind of
like do some rapid fire like let's
listen a minute on some questions Oh
something else why I don't want to
disappoint people because I know we
raised the Russian sentence oh yes so
maybe yes give away the punchline there
yeah okay talk about the Russian
sentence so let's remind everyone what
it was again so the sentence was more
people have been to Russia than I have
this is known as a grammatical allusion
it's an allusion in the sense that it's
it usually sounds pretty good to people
and when you ask them to describe what
it actually means people either have a
really hard time explaining what it
means or to the extent that they can
give an explanation those explanations
just don't converge you get one group of
people saying that it means this for
sure and another group of people saying
it means that for sure it's kind of like
the the dress that broke the internet a
few years ago right half of the angle
were saying was white and gold the other
half we're saying black and blue yeah
hashtag team white and gold for this but
I know it was actually black anyway so
this sentence kind of breaks people's
brains a little bit and really you know
it's an interesting case of an
experiment being able to uncover it was
has been researching to use grammatical
allusions and what seems to be going on
and the short version is that yeah what
does seem to be going on in these
sentences in terms of why they sound
good even though they don't really seem
to mean all that much when you really
dig into them because again if you think
about it more people have been to Russia
than I have well then I have what like
okay you counting the number of people
that have been to Russia and you're
comparing that to the number of you that
have been to Russia yeah yeah it kind of
works but it's also kind of weird and it
turns out that the biggest variable that
seems to be influencing how good or bad
these these illusory sentences sound is
the kind of verb that's actually put
into the sentence so it turns out that
sentences which have a verb
like let's say jump or maybe you won't
want to pick a transitive verb like
phoned their parents so let's say more
people have phoned their parents than I
have that census sound pretty good and
the reason is that phoning your parents
is something that you can do multiple
times it's not something that you only
do once in your life so it seems like
what's being compared is the number of
times that some group of people have
done this activity like phoning their
parents there's a number of times you've
done that activity and these sentences
get worse when you put in a verb that
can't be repeated like graduated high
school right so more Pat more people
have graduated high school than I have I
mean again it kind of makes sense but
it's weirder and in principle it's
weirder because you don't generally
graduate high school more than once in
your life right um and so you can't
really count that happening in the same
way that you can count how many times
you phone your parents and so you find
this when you control for all other
factors and you just kind of swap out
the verbs in these sentences you get
better or worse sounding sentences and
what's interesting is this doesn't
really match up with people's
impressions of how these sentences work
there's there's a big disconnect between
what people subjectively feel is going
on in these sentences versus what
experiment just fine which is at the end
of the day I think a great argument for
why you want to study these things
scientifically why you can't really rely
on your own personal feelings or
subjective issues about something you
kind of want to design an experiment
come up with a Office's yeah Farra what
it predicts and then see if that
prediction comes true yeah great
so yeah rapid-fire questions yeah
rapid-fire questions so like a minute or
less try not to talk too long on these
why are certain words forbidden in a
society uh yeah that that tends to be
associated with particular things you
know often it gets associated with
bodily functions so if something is sort
of kind of gross or or you know
health-related you can get words that
are end up being taboo words that are
taboo interesting enough here in Quebec
tend to be very much tied to religion
right so things like and
warning here to our Quebec French
speakers but things like pabeth Mac then
tend to be pretty bad and and in that
case it's it's associated more with the
taboo surrounding religion which is kind
of a unique phenomenon here on Quebec
we've become a very secular society well
I noticed I noticed in America I say can
I use your bathroom you say can I use
your washroom yeah in England they say
can I use your toilet yeah yeah and
toilet is the most descriptive as it's
the thing that you're going to you know
use and so in America we've we've kind
of made that taboo and we say bathroom
even though there's almost never a bad
yeah if you had a restaurant you still
ask for the bathroom and you use the
washroom which yeah there you can
usually wash yourself in there but I
think that's interesting and then we
also have so I think there's also an
association with oh did this word come
from a lower what what mainstream
society thinks of as a lower-class
subculture did the word come from there
if so it's taboo Diaz yeah sure or a
more versus less prestigious language
you know one one kind of language you
know let's say if word has been borrowed
from Latin or Greek it's probably viewed
with high prestige around you know
versus a language versus a word which
maybe has been borrowed from a language
which is a desk sort of socially
prestigious let's say and then of course
we have Saint like things that were
associated with harassment in the past
so now you can't say them so the n-word
is the obvious one in English way I mean
I usually usually social labels and
acquiring a taboo over time and have to
be replaced is actually this phenomenon
known as the euphemism conveyor belt oh
yeah or the UM is a treadmill I should
say yeah because what usually ends up
happening is you'll replace one with
label with another because the label is
required a negative connotation but
because unfortunately you have an
eliminated discrimination and and right
unlike from society the new label ends
up acquiring the bad connotation and you
have to replace it yet again right well
so it used to be normal to
if someone had a mental disability to
say that they are mentally [ __ ] yeah
you cannot say that now yeah right and
even mental disability is being replaced
with oh this person is mentally diverse
sure yeah yeah neuro neuro-diverse
versus neurotypical is one of the newer
and that sister so this is a conveyor
belt and it's gonna keep changing and it
is all until there's no longer they do
about yeah that's really interesting so
we went over that one but then okay can
you guys remind us of your channel name
we already did that
Jonathan Jonathan Jerry oh yeah why are
there seemingly fewer distinctive
accents throughout English Canada versus
England or is this indeed true I I
suspect its sure I don't know for sure
right I mean there is sort of this this
trope that you know you can tell what
blocks someone lives on in England the
Pentagon their accent like it's it's
that discreet in that discrim writing
whereas English you know you do find
some differences you know there's a
dialect of Montreal English that I speak
which is different from how someone who
grew up in Calgary speaks but it's not
dramatic you know the most dramatic
differences you find are let's say
standard Canadian English to the extent
that there is such a thing versus
Newfoundland English which tends to be
pretty pronounced as a different dialect
I'm not sure if I can answer the why
question it's not something I've given
enough thought to I think I can I think
I might be able to answer that or just
give up my own hypothesis that Canada is
much younger than England is true and
we've had radio and other forms of
26-point it's a good thing that make
things universal like right now the the
English that has no accent is the
English spoken in Hollywood for me yeah
yeah I mean again has no accent here is
a relative yeah it's more how it's
perceived but that's it that's an
interesting point yo as I mentioned
earlier it couldn't turn out to be the
case that English changes more slowly
now that there is this kind of
external standard by which English is
English and that we can compare
ourselves to it'll be interesting to see
what happens over the next house here's
someone Stacey Thompson just mentioned I
learned a lot about nonverbal
communication after getting a cat
I find this super interesting the amount
of communication we can have with
animals is quite spectacular I mean my
dog understands if I'm angry at them not
knowing at all what language I speak I
mean I my dogs here were raised with
French so they do understand a lot of
French words but when I come here and I
yelling at them in English they know
exactly what I'm saying they they have
no problem with it and they're very good
at reading language and I suppose that
we were good at reading which before our
our species if you were to follow us
back in time before we had developed
language we could tell if someone was
upset and why they were upset just by
looking at them maybe maybe it would
just be worth adding on here that you
know in a way your dog does understand
what you're saying and in a way they
don't right so you could yell a very
positive message or a very negative one
and they'll take the same message from
that you know they won't understand the
propositional content of the message you
know you could scream I love you or you
could scream I hate you in the other
case you dogs probably gonna think
you're pretty pissed off whereas of
course as humans we do understand that
those sentences mean completely
different things I mean that's that's
language right it's it's that
Association of discrete combinations of
sounds with with complex ideas I almost
see why do people not all understand
phenome based languages Oh phoneme based
language well I'm I'm not I'm not
totally sure here what's meant by
phoneme based language so a phoneme all
languages have phonemes so phonemes are
just the distinctive sounds that a
language uses to distinguish one word
from another so you know we talked about
this at the beginning of the
conversation a P and B are phonemes in
English because if you replace
peeps sound with a B sound you get a
different words so a pat is different
from a bat whereas other languages don't
make this distinction so it sounded a B
sound aren't phonemes the sounds still
exist but they aren't separated in the
same way that they are spin us in the
head of an English speaker yeah yeah I'm
trying to understand what the question
means here I mean certainly different
writing systems for different languages
can more more or less transparent Li
reflect the sounds of that language
I mean English is kind of notorious for
how poorly our writing system reflects
the way that the language is actually
spoken we have a very irregular spelling
system that it has all kinds of silent
G's and HS and look can someone be born
with a disability that makes them blind
to sound differences so I've heard of
like face blindness yeah but can't
recognize someone by their face I would
imagine we have similar disabilities
that's a really interesting question I I
would love to find out if that's true I
have no idea but it wouldn't totally
surprise me if that were the case and
that kind of level of discrimination
seems to be so uniquely human and if
it's associated with let's say a
particular brain region that were to
take damage maybe they would lose that
ability or never acquire it yeah do you
think that language gave us an advantage
over Neanderthals you might not be as
super up-to-date on current research on
Neanderthals but I yeah we do not know
how much language they had it was
assumed in the past they didn't have
much language but we actually those
conclusions have been very poorly mmm
founded yeah all I can really say here
is that it's a tough question to answer
how old language is I mean the timespan
is enormous
it can be as a recent as maybe you know
hundred thousand years ago then we've
had language to a million or two I mean
it probably it hasn't existed in in one
form I mean we're not supposing here
that it popped up fully formed that's
not generally how a cognitive or a
biological feature arises I know much
rather than write yet much better than I
do
um so it can be tricky I mean that's one
of the trickiest things to study because
language doesn't leave a fossil it's not
really something you can dig up and look
at writing is not the same as language
so we can't really look at writing as
it's a relatively recent invention
raining him one form another has only
been around for about six five six
thousand years and even then it took a
few thousand to get to the it's only
been independently invented a handful of
times and it it usually has to go
through a lot of stages to get to where
writing exists today which is an
alphabetic system where individual
graphemes represent individual phonemes
and can sort of reliably replicate the
language in a way that actually
accurately transmits information yeah
it's a tough question yeah so just as
far as why did we do better than the
Neanderthals I I've looked at a lot of
different hypotheses about this and I
don't think that any of them are solid
enough to like really say this is why we
succeeded and they did not I mean first
of all we interbred with rain so we're
all a little bit date you're told yeah
I'm not all this actually oh really
you're a-- pians only oh thing interests
the most Africans that haven't mixed
with your rains yet at all don't have
you're not healthy so we have yeah it's
mysterious maybe they died off because
the disease and they were they didn't
died off because they had less taboos
and we did so interbreeding with us was
fine for them but it was weird for us so
it yeah I who knows it's it's it's a
mystery but let's see I think we should
probably wrap this up since 1121 here
mac taylor asks did he explain that the
eye
he wasn't here for this start he's
asking if we already explained your
t-shirt and all rest we did we did so
you can watch that later when you're
real watching this and yeah I'm I'm a
new uncle today I just learned from my
brother in the comments Oh
congratulations so that's pretty awesome
thanks for your pointing that out Mike
but you know more
people have become uncles than you have
yeah more people become uncles than I
have um and then I just want to leave
you with a final sentence a friend of
mine invented it always takes longer
than it does and this is a really funny
sentence to think about and
unfortunately we didn't have chance to
talk about this but you actually spent
alone a long time thinking about that
and analyzing that sentence it always
takes longer than it does why is that
sentence weird and funny and why does
that make you think so
with that stay curious everyone
it was wonderful thank you for coming on
the show a good time again the YouTube
channel is the Ling space
and you can learn the basics of
linguistics there you can learn you can
see really cool interviews steven pinker
and dan Dennett and so on
ah thank you thank you for shading it
yeah my pleasure
and stop broadcast